this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by Skillshare home to
over 20,000 classes that could teach you
a new life skill the Ford Model T was
not the first car
not even close depending on how you
define what a car is that honor was
achieved 100 years before Henry Ford was
even born in 1769 when French engineer
Nikola Joseph Kuno created this
steam-powered vehicle designed to travel
off rail the honor for the first true
automobile goes to Carole Benz founder
of mercedes-benz in 1885 with this
single piston two-stroke gasoline
powered vehicle the heirs of the
automobile was well under development
before Henry Ford hit the scene no Ford
did not invent the automobile he
invented something much more profound he
created modern society that is a massive
claim but bear with me his manufacturing
techniques did not just revolutionize
how we design and build everything
making complicated machinery like
tractors and cars affordable for the
masses his manufacturing techniques
radically changed the trajectories of
billions of people's careers at the turn
of the 18th century craft manufacturing
was the status quo defined by a highly
skilled workforce people wishing to
pursue a career in automotive
manufacturing entered their career and
progressed through an apprenticeship
picking up a huge variety of skills
gradually learning the tricks of the
trade and been masters of their craft
money would go on to run their own
machine shops these were less employees
and more contractors in these days a
machine like an automobile was not built
entirely in-house parts would come from
smaller machine shops from all over the
city
they used general purpose tools and
machines to create the parts needed
which would be sent to the final
assembler these parts would vary
massively from one batch to another
requiring a skilled assembling team
workers needed to understand the
function of the part they were working
on and skillfully manipulate the parts
together into the final vehicle there
was no mass manufacturing of complex
machines like this each vehicle was one
of a kind commissioned by whoever was
wealthy enough to afford it at this
production volume no company could
create a monopoly there were hundreds of
small craft shops like this across
Western Europe and North America
but
would soon be run out of business by
Henry Ford before they had the chance to
adopt his mass manufacturing techniques
only the best craft manufacturer
survived companies like Aston Martin and
Bentley succeeded by focusing on the
ultra-wealthy that could afford these
one-off vehicles using skilled craftsmen
to build unique and luxurious cars but
even they would soon have to join the
movement to survive all eventually being
bought out by these mass production
powerhouses no longer able to keep up
with the cost of innovation and
manufacturing required to keep pace in
the automotive industry at the high
point of the Model T success in 1923
Ford was manufacturing 2.1 million Model
T's a year a figure that would only be
matched by a single vehicle model again
with the VW Beetle many people chalk
Henry Ford's success down to in
flexibility and designed the famous
quote you can have any color as long as
it's black this was true for many years
but perhaps not for the reasons you
think you see Henry Ford was obsessed
with manufacturing speeds the painting
process he used allowed the paint to dry
quickly and it was only available in
black at that time he shaved time off
wherever possible to achieve that
monumental milestone of 2.1 million
Model T's a year the Model T was no
fluke it was the culmination in over 20
design iterations over five years each
one tweaking the design and
manufacturing procedure to cut seconds
off the total process and the
innovations continued through the nearly
20 years of production that would see a
total of 15 million Model T's
manufactured Ford worked all his life to
learn the skills needed to achieve this
goal which you can learn more about by
watching this video by my friends over
at business casual but we will start our
story on the first day of production for
the Model T in 1908 the average task
cycle for the Model T on that day lasted
514 minutes the task cycle time is the
length of time before a single task is
repeated so the average worker did not
repeat a task for 8 and a half hours for
Ford
this was essentially how long a single
production line was producing vehicles
as assembly lines cannot start a new
vehicle until another has exited at the
other end so he set to work on reducing
that cycle time and by 1913 he managed
to bring it down to just 2 point 3
minutes for a product this complex
consisting of hundreds of parts with
hundreds of processes that is astounding
and was something no other company had
ever achieved how on earth did Ford
achieved this quantum leap forward in
manufacturing speed let's first start
with the innovations that Ford was not
responsible for that allowed him to
begin this journey as I said one of the
reasons highly skilled workers were
essential to these industries before
Ford came along was because of the high
variability between parts in engineering
we call this tolerancing when I worked
as a design engineer I needed to specify
the tolerances I needed for specific
part features say I needed a shaft to
fit a particular hole I needed to
specify how much the machinist was
permitted to deviate from the listed
dimension if I have a 20 millimeter hole
paired with a 19 millimeter shaft and I
specified that both can deviate from
that dimension by plus or minus 0.5
millimeters even at the extreme ends of
both where both are nineteen point five
millimeters wide they will still fit
with some force this may not be
acceptable depending on application and
higher tolerancing may be needed which
generally means an increase in cost
engineer screw up these things even
today but in ford's day consistently
achieving a tolerance that tight in mass
manufacturing would have been a huge
task and was generally something saved
for military applications and not for
low-cost consumer products this was
largely due to the mass manufacturing
techniques of the day specifically heat
treatment methods as explained in my
knife forging and aluminium videos
metals need to be heated and cooled in
specific ways to strengthen or harden
the metal but this makes the metal much
harder to cut and shape so the metals
were often cut first and heat treated
after this heating and cooling causes
the metal to deform due to the thermal
expansion which can then throw the
original piece out of Tolerance this is
called warping and it made it nylon
impossible to get a consistent final
product many attribute Ford with
revolutionizing the standardization of
parts but in truth he was simply at the
right place at the right time to benefit
from technologies that facilitated it
new methods for coating and stamping pre
hardened metals allowed for to eliminate
much of this variability jutsu
warping advancements of precision
measurement and manufacturing allowed
for it to be confident that parts would
be interchangeable and in turn
this allowed Ford to design his vehicles
in a way that reduced costs this was the
dawn of destruction for the craft
manufacturing industry and the beginning
of a movement that would change the face
of modern society while his competitors
were casting each cylinder of their
engine blocks separately and bolting
them together due to the difficulty in
casting a single part with multiple
holes that needed to line up precisely
ford casted a single complex engine
block that drastically reduced the time
required to manufacture and assemble it
this of course led to incredibly
expensive dedicated machinery needed to
manufacture a single piece of the
vehicle in the world of craft
manufacturing a skilled worker could use
a general purpose tool and skillfully
use it to produce the final product in
the world of mass manufacturing this was
not acceptable it took too long and
required skilled workers who were too
difficult to replace
for example engine blocks consists of an
upper and lower part that need to make
perfectly to maintain a seal for engine
compression affords competitors like
Cadillac used a single flexible milling
machine to create a flush surface on
both the upper and lower house of the
engine block engine blocks and heads
were loaded and milled slowly and
precisely one at a time Ford instead
created dedicated machines to mill
engine blocks and engine heads
separately 15 and 30 at a time
respectively workers simply snapped the
unmilled pieces into a tray while the
previous slot was being milled and then
pushed the tray into place when the time
came a worker could be trained in five
minutes to do this task they didn't need
to speak the same language as the person
next to them they didn't need to think
about anything else
just feed the machine like the little
butter passing robot of Rick and Morty
what is my purpose you pass butter
oh my god these people had a single
purpose
this of course resulted in inflexibility
in design the cost of introducing an
entirely new model vehicle was
drastically increased and this is why
even today car brands tend to iterate on
old designs rather than introduced
entirely new models it's simply too
expensive and time-consuming to retrofit
entire production lines when Ford
eventually decided to completely
redesign the Model T and produce the
Model A these machines were thrown out
but he had achieved his goal cycle times
were lowering and there was still room
to improve
Ford managed to half cycle times from
two point three minutes to one point two
minutes with his next innovation when
production first started on the Model T
employees worked from a stationary work
stand if they needed a Parrish or tool
they would get up and get it themselves
Ford soon recognized the wastes and
introduced dedicated stock suppliers
whose only job was to ensure that other
workers had the parts they needed to
keep production running at a constant
pace where possible these employees were
replaced with automated supply lines
this idea grew and evolved to the
introduction of Ford's greatest
manufacturing innovation the moving
assembly line a manufacturing technique
still in use today even for huge
machines like planes
this is Boeing's moving assembly line
for the triple 7 which carries the
entire 166 ton plane across the factory
floor gradually adding the three million
parts needed to complete it this method
introduces a sense of urgency to the
factory floor an ever looming deadline
to complete your work before the plane
reaches the next production step if
there is a critical problem the entire
production line will literally stop
moving until it's fixed Ford was not the
first to introduce such an idea they had
been used in simple production lines for
butchering of Kara cases and food
preparation before but never for
anything this complex and Ford applied
it as a science using his engineering
skills to help pioneer a new branch of
engineering Industrial Engineering the
branch of engineering mostly concerned
with optimizing the logistics of
manufacturing spend a few hours plane
factorial and you will really gain an
appreciation for the complexity of this
profession
it starts off simple but as your factory
grows you need to carefully manage your
production speeds to avoid pile ups you
need to plan and place your production
units to maximize transportation speeds
and get the products where they need to
be one of the huge problems you run into
is faster production units producing
items faster than you need them further
up the line causing pile ups of stock
that can back up and actually block
other production units before you know
it
production has grinded to a halt the
moving assembly line forces all workers
to work at the same pace faster workers
can't produce items faster than they are
needed and slower workers can't slack
off ford's innovations catapulted the
Ford Motor Company to international
success but that dominance would not
last forever companies came from all
over the world to observe Ford's
factories they marveled at how the
factory itself was like a finely tuned
machine each part feeding into the other
and they took their lessons home and by
1955 mass manufacturing had proliferated
around the world and soon companies
outside the US were not just catching up
with the big three of Detroit Ford
General Motors and Cadillac but far
exceeding their capabilities most
notably Toyota in post-world War two
Japan who led a revolution in
manufacturing through a new
manufacturing philosophy lean
manufacturing
this graph shows all vehicles produced
by region after 1955 showing the
explosion and growth in Japan with the
advent of lean manufacturing that would
lead to Detroit's eventual demise
Detroit would soon become a ghost town
and just as these companies viewed their
machines as disposable they viewed their
employees as disposable dropping them
the moment demand tanked this problem
has only got worse zero hour contracts
and strict control of unions is common
Ford actually paid his workers
incredibly well for the time but that
meant little when demand dropped and
these workers had few transferrable
skills to gain new employment for better
or worse
Ford's innovations completely changed
the job market for billions of people I
was one of those people working 12-hour
shifts with only one task way a stent
and pass it to the next step during that
time I made extra efforts to learn new
skills outside of work to keep myself
sane one way to learn new skills is
through skill
chair and why not start by learning
about the stock market with this course
from my friends at business casual who
have also just made a video about Henry
Ford's rise to success on their channel
this is just one in over 20,000 classes
you could take on Skillshare that range
from creative skills like painting and
music lessons to technical skills like
coding with professional and
understandable classes that follow a
clear learning curve you can dive in and
start learning how to do the work you
love a premium membership begins around
$10 a month for unlimited access to all
courses for the first 1,000 people to
sign up with this link will get their
first two months for free so ask
yourself right now what skill have you
been putting off learning while projects
have you been dreaming of completing but
you aren't sure if you have the skills
to do it why not start right now and
sign up to skill share using the link
below to get your first two months for
free you have nothing to lose and a
valuable life skill to gain as usual
thanks for watching and thank you to all
my patreon supporters a link to that
video by business casual is on screen
now if you'd like to see more from me
the links to my Twitter Facebook discord
server subreddit and Instagram pages are
below
[Music]